ever since Avengers infinity war ended
fans have been speculating over just
who's going to actually be in 2019 s
Avengers for rumors are swirling that
the film will feature pretty much every
character in the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe with stars revealing they
filmed one scene that included nearly
three dozen heroes one in particular
scene there's like thirty two there's a
lot there's so many of us but it turns
out some of your favorites still won't
join the party why here's a look at some
Marvel characters who will not be in
Avengers for Adam warlock Avengers for
co-director Joe Russo dashed the hopes
of some fans when he made it clear Adam
warlock would not be appearing in
Avengers 4 warlock was a pivotal figure
in the 1991 comic book miniseries
Infinity Gauntlet from which Avengers
infinity war takes much of its
inspiration one of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2's mid-credits seems fed
fans expectations that warlock would
appear in either infinity war or its
sequel I think I shall call him
but regardless Rousseau told
comicbook.com it isn't happening I have
no interest as a director and telling a
story that's already been told or in
scene one that's already been told if I
know all the events as they're going to
happen what's the point of going to the
film Plus with director James Gunn no
longer running the guardians of the
galaxy franchise there's no telling now
whether warlock will ever show up at all
bummer the x-men and the Fantastic Four
in spite of rumors to the contrary
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
insists that neither the x-men nor the
Fantastic Four will appear in Avengers 4
even if Disney's planned acquisition of
Fox goes through as planned
partly because Avengers 4 has already
been filmed and the editing process has
already begun
Feige told The Daily News that when it
comes to the x-men and the Fantastic
Four potentially joining the MCU I have
vague dreams and vague ideas but right
now bringing to life the 10,000 plus
characters that Marvel fully controls is
what the game plan is Marvel's Netflix
heroes if you're hoping to see the cast
of Netflix as defenders or Punisher and
Avengers 4 you should probably go ahead
and feel the disappointment now in March
2018 Joe Russo told premiere the Netflix
heroes were considered for inclusion in
Avengers infinity war but it would have
been too much to juggle especially with
so many different directors involved the
trick is that we already have at least
60 characters with whom we must tell a
story and it's hard enough to
communicate with Taika Waititi ryan
coogler scott derrickson Peyton Reed and
James Gunn at the same time not to add
all the showrunners and TV crews to this
so it's practically impossible our job
is to focus on the Marvel film world and
offer a satisfying climax of course in
the interview Russo was talking
specifically about infinity war not
Avengers 4 but it's safe to assume it
applies to Avengers 4 as well Silver
Surfer before the release of Avengers
infinity war rumors flew around the web
that Silver Surfer would make a surprise
appearance in the film spoilers he
didn't and while the rumor mill is just
getting started when it comes to
Avengers 4 you probably shouldn't
believe any reports you hear about
Silver Surfer making a cameo in it
like the x-men and the Fantastic Four
the rights to Silver Surfer are held up
in the Disney Foxx acquisition even if
that gets resolved before
Avengers 4 comes out expect Silver
Surfer to make his debut later rather
than sooner Deadpool as soon as Disney's
attempt to acquire Fox was announced
deadpool star ryan reynolds trolled the
mouse house by retweeting a picture of
deadpool bean escorted out of disneyland
later after the success of Avengers
infinity war Reynolds tweeted
congratulations to the team by posting
what he said was his Avengers rejection
letter from Tony Stark
hey given what happened to his last team
can you really blame them but there is a
slight chance Bannister could make but
while fans have pushed all sorts of
theories about how and why Deadpool may
make a surprise appearance in Avengers 4
it seems very unlikely given Deadpool
faces the same rights challenges as the
x-men Fantastic Four and Silver Surfer
for the time being he'll just have to do
as the Avengers rejection letter
suggested and stick with bothering
Professor X that potts with the giant
pigeon wings
what are those do anyway carrying three
feet off the ground is snatch up the
nearest muffin crumb
[Music]